hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from the super United
rabbit and Blitz tournament currently
being played in Croatia it is Magnus
Carlsen against one of his second siren
pump arrest uh we've seen a game in the
previous video where janipomishi lost
terribly to evancharich who is also a
member of Magnus Carlsen Camp they both
helped Magnus prepare for his World
Church championship match against the
animation but here we will see how
Magnus deals with Jordan's
um a very interesting approach to the uh
to the English opening and a very
interesting position arises already as
of move eight so let's see uh what
happens Magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with C4 he opted for the
English opening with E5 they are going
for The King's English variation G3 and
D5 now striking in the center right away
captures captures now the queen attacks
The Rook on H1 and of course Knight to
F3 with knights the C6 and not Knight
the C3 and uh I believe at the time this
game was played Jordan was co-leading
the tournament with alireza so if Jordan
can get a draw or a win here it would uh
definitely go a long way Queen back to
d8 and now Bishop to G2 now this has all
been played before Knight to F6 uh we
have Castles by Magnus in the now Bishop
to E7 and here there are a couple of uh
games that reach this position but in
none of them at the move that Magnus
actually plays uh was played and here
Magnus plays the move from the thumbnail
and that is Pawn to B4 uh great it is
definitely the best move in this
position but it is also uh you know a
fairly good move in some other positions
none come to mind at the moment but I'm
sure you guys are familiar with some of
them so here how do you continue Can you
capture the pawn is Knight captures or
Bishop captures an option well Knight
captures not so real you lose the E5
Pawn but uh funny thing is if Bishop
captures you also uh give up D5 pawn and
now after Knight captures we just play
Queen day for check and now we're gonna
pick up the bishop or if if Knight goes
back defends the bishop now we eliminate
the defender of the bishop upon captures
Queen captures here it's equal material
but we've messed up black spawn
structure and the white is much better
here preventing black from castling it's
uh
it's just a bad position for black so
instead after they spawn to B4 which is
a new move uh we have pawned the E for
uh chasing away the Knight so we don't
have to worry about Knight captures and
E5 and only after Knight the G5 is
played now Jordan plays Bishop captures
on B4 we have knighted G captures on e4
by Magnus Knight captures with Knight
captures and now you're just castles
with A3 chasing away the bishop Bishop
to A7 and now Bishop to B2 uh the
material is completely even both players
have the bishop pair however Magnus does
have the strong Center and you will see
just what a strong Center can mean for a
chess game so Rook to E8 we have rooked
the C1 and both players just continuing
development in the bishop to f8 giving
the the E file to The Rook however uh
also guarding that G7 Pawn you know that
it's gonna be a problem at some point so
E3 we have Bishop to F5 and now Knight
the C5 attacking the B7 Pawn so Rook to
B8 and now Pawn to D4 starting to
control that Center we have Knight to A5
and now Pawn to E4 attacking the bishop
Bishop G6 and now F4 now like I said
equal material but look at uh magnus's
central control here so B6 chasing away
the Knight and now Magnus plays Knight
the A6 attacks the rook and also the C7
Pawn it's attacked twice now so Bishop
captures an E4 Now problem is if you
play something like Rook the C8 F5 traps
the bishop and Jordan cannot allow this
so instead he goes for Bishop captures
on e4 uh he grabs a pawn but will have
to give up the exchange and okay Bishop
captures through a captures and now
Magnus grabs the rook and B8 Knight
captures Queen captures and now Rook the
E1 offers a rook trade so he is up the
exchange but Jordan is up upon and it's
um well Magnus still has to work very
hard for his meal so Rook captures Queen
captures and queen to d8 now uh we have
Queen to C3 now you don't have to worry
about something like D5 and queen
captures and G7 as the bishop is nicely
positioned here but as long as it's
nicely positioned he positions here here
it's not really all that useful
somewhere else so C6 uh also the C7 Pawn
is hanging so uh Jordan just pushes it
to C6 we have Queen to F3 now uh and
pawn to B5 now here uh with with a move
like H6 the game uh still uh is somewhat
playable but after they spawn the B5
move uh Jordan allows the Magnus uh
truly a brilliant uh idea to be executed
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this basically only move
that allows Magnus to push this game for
a win while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh I
mean a crazy idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Ponta D5 yes it seems like really weird
but uh usually in positions uh you know
where you really have a problem with
your own Pawn your own Pawn is blocking
the bishop uh sometimes that's all you
have to do and here there's even a
special trick involved because if black
would play Queen captures on D5 then D5
would be a silly move however if Queen
captures on D5 then we win on the spot
just Queen captures on d5c captures and
Rook to C8 and black resigns there is no
defense against Bishop C3 Bishop B4
whoops that's a wrong arrow and the
bishop on f8 will fall even if black
tries to defend lithium ic4 attacks the
bishop now Knight c396 attacks The Rook
uh still not a problem or even if maybe
even better Bishop to D for let's say
Knight to D6 attacks The Rook we just
move the Rook and now again Bishop to C5
is coming there is no useful move to
make and if you try something like F6
Bishop C5 and King f72 and pin the
bishop so now the bishop can capture the
Knight now you fall for Rook captures
and f8 King captures and Bishop captures
Here and Now white is up a full piece
and of course completely winning so
that's why here D5 is so strong so this
is what Magnus played and now you don't
really have a good reply to this you
could go uh something like Queen to B6
uh King moves and then C5 but then
Magnus gets to the Past C the past D
Pawn or you go for uh what Jordan played
C captures on D5 and now Rook to D1 now
the pawns are much much weaker and uh
magnets will of course win the d-pawn
Knight the C4 attacks the bishop but
just Rook captures on D5 we have Queen
t7 now comes at Bishop to D4 and again
you cannot go after the a pawn even
though that'd be great because then
Jordan would have to connect the past
pawns but if Knight captures just Bishop
C5 and of course again you resign uh and
um uh if Queen captures an A3 which
seems possible as uh you you can trade
Queens it still doesn't work captures
captures and now after Rook to d8 again
no defense against Bishop to C5 so you
can see that even though this bishop is
a great defender it's also a pretty big
liability here so after Bishop D4 Queen
to E1 check by Jordan uh we have King
the G2 by Magnus and the now Queen back
to E8 not allowing um a Magnus to occupy
the back rank with the Rook uh Bishop
captures an A7 and only now Bishop
captures on A3 with Bishop active too
and now Bishop back to f8 so now Jordan
does have the pass B Pawn uh but uh it
is it's not very easy to push it we have
Queen to D3 now going for Queen to d8
and we have Queen to A8 now pinning The
Rook King to H3 and now Queen the C8
with check hoping for King to G2 and
queen 38 maybe he can get a repetition
but Magnus not interested he just pushes
F5 and now we have Bishop to E7 of
course we have to see what happens if
Pawn to B4 if this is playable then it
could be a problem for Magnus but just
Bishop C5 and Jordan can resign there's
nothing to play here the Knight is
hanging uh also just uh you know Rook 38
will be a problem Bishop captures Queen
captures let's say a rook to date will
win the queen so here you're gonna have
to play Bishop captures on C5 but then
Queen characters and C4 and again Bishop
will fall you're up a full Rook
completely winning so after F5 Bishop to
E7 by Jordan uh but now comes Rook
captures on B5 and without this Pawn
there really is no counter play here so
H5 finally creating some breeding room
for the king and also now starting uh uh
you know just a total attack against the
the white king because that's your only
chance maybe Magnus blund or something
Rook to D5 and now Pawn to G5 with uh
King back to G2 and queen to C6 now
again pinning The Rook but now King to
G1 Magnus never actually had to go to H3
he couldn't just play King to G1 to
start with but you know he I guess he
had his reasons uh Bishop to D6 uh this
is one last trick but Magnus does not
fall for it he just plays Rook to D4 now
attacks the Knight the Knight has to
move and then the bishop will fall so
Knights the E5 and now Rook captures on
D6 saying okay you capture my queen I'm
gonna capture your queen so here Knight
the F3 with check and here yeah Magnus
played King to H1 and he was in this
position on move 43 that Jordan pump
Forest resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here but it's
it's an interesting try even though
you're done material if Magnus for some
reason plays King to G2 King F1 and King
H1 are fine but if he plays King to G2
then you run into this most unpleasant
double check Knight E1 it's a double
check from the queen and the Knight and
then the King has to move if you go to
the back rank let's say here of course
you get checkmated it doesn't help if
you go to H3 Queen to G2 is still
Checkmate so your only option here would
be to play King to F1 but this still
loses because we just moved the queen
with check and next move we pick up the
White Queen so Bishop G1 Knight captures
here and yes okay you're gonna capture
the nightbot queen against bishop and
Rook um uh wins this easily uh so Magnus
of course avoided this after Knight F3
checking each one was played and uh it
was like I said in this position that
you wouldn't resigned the game and the
Magnus gets a very very important
victory for the tournament standings but
we're gonna show one more game from the
final round from the final day of the
rapid and then we are going to discuss
the standings and how how it went for
everyone uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it as the two of
them really know each other well they've
prepared together uh to beat Yan in the
world's championship match it's very
hard to surprise
um uh you know uh either of them but
here you're you're in tried with a with
with the specialty but Magnus was ready
and at the right moment where no one
before played it he played B4 and that
was enough to win the game obviously uh
so yeah I really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Gordon Mercer
tank control over all right Travis and
Michael Colbert and Kevin Klein for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as you usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day